some folks have jokingly called the
bipartisan campaign reform act BCRA or
mccain feingold they've said what it
really stands for before campaigning
retain attorney the laws purpose was
always kind of vague I mean shifting it
was sold to the American people as it's
like kind of like a 19th century patent
medicine it's good for what ails you do
you think campaigns are too negative you
want mccain-feingold you think they're
too long you want McCain final you think
too much is spent you want mccain
feingold you think they're too nasty you
want mccain feingold you just hate
politics you want mccain feingold and as
a result there is nothing it's very
tough to measure by any standard but but
what was generally promised to people
was that it would get money out of
politics and it would kind of clean up
politics now how has that worked in a
broad sense I hardly know anybody who
would say that those goals have been
achieved or that that vicar has
accomplished its goals if anything
campaign seemed longer and more negative
and more expensive than before and the
in terms of corruption I mean the era of
mccain feingold is the era of bob ney
and Jack Abramoff and what was at 70 or
90 thousand dollars in congressman
Jefferson's refrigerator in his office
you could say that the era of mccain
feingold is an error of corruption in
american politics as great as we've seen
since Watergate
you can't stop citizens from coming
together and spending money to talk
about politics and you have to
understand a little background of the
law I mean it points up the absurdity of
the whole thing the Supreme Court has
held that because there's no corruption
in sort of spending money if I were
multi-millionaire I could just go out
and spend my money it's not going to
corrupt a candidate so an individual can
spend as much as he where she wants an
independent expenditures a George Soros
or Bill Gates or someone can just go out
and spend he wants a million dollars or
20 million dollars to support a
particular candidate but according to
the FEC what there are you in court is
once that person gets together with
someone else then neither of them can
spend more than five thousand dollars on
the effort so this seems like a very odd
rule and it's more than infringes on
freedom of association and a lot of
people say well you know still that only
really affects fat cats you know who can
afford to get more than five thousand
dollars you know but but part of the the
issue in speech now is that many of the
members of speech now are small donors
who cannot give large sums and what
gives their voice power what allows them
to be heard in a political system is
being able to join together with
wealthier individuals who can contribute
a hundred thousand dollars or fifty
thousand dollars into the campaign
that's what makes them heard and that's
what the current law prevents
let me ask you this question imagine if
George Bush were to announced here in
the fading twilight of his presidency
that in order to prevent terrorists from
infiltrating American political parties
in the succeeding control or American
government we need to have we need to
introduce the Patriot to act and the
Patriot to act would require citizens to
report to the government their political
activities and the government would keep
that in a database which by the way they
would then make available to private
individuals like employers or maybe
groups that might want to protest
outside your home as to what your
political activities were what do you
think would be the reaction to that law
well I don't know I know some people i
think would support there was a great
idea I know on America's political left
would go berserk they would go
absolutely nuts well you know what we
have that law already and it's called
campaign finance it's called the federal
election campaign act which requires you
to report to the government requires the
campaign's to report to the government
people who give them money right and the
government keeps that in a database and
they make that available to your anybody
can go online and look at stuff up on
the internet
there may be some benefits to disclosure
of at least large contributions but at a
minimum you know it seems like we don't
need to be disclosing you know every
penny instantly over the Internet your
people say that sometimes you know even
even those who generally as I do favor
deregulating in the system but they're
kind of but will disclose everything and
they usually pound the table show how
serious they are about this instantly on
the internet you know every penny I'm
like though we don't need every penny we
don't need it instantly one of the
things that disclosure also does beyond
the privacy invasion is it's one of the
toughest things for grassroots
organizations for true small-timers you
know political newbies we might say to
comply with for example let's suppose I
decided to start a little political
committee and I'm going to you know
lobby on some state ballot issue or I'm
going to try to support candidates or
whatever it is it's pretty easy for me
to grasp some of the basic rules okay I
can't take maybe in the state I can't
take any corporate contributions I can't
take any contributions over ten thousand
dollars or 1000 pounds or evidence those
are pretty easy rules to explain to the
treasure and everybody knows that what's
hard is filing all the reports that's
what takes time and expertise and that a
lot of people have a great deal of
difficulty doing so these disclosure
regimes further professionalize politics
and make it harder for the average
citizen to participate in politics
John McCain and I have really met on
just one occasion and Senator McCain had
very often said you know a number of
things about me that I thought were
often insulting and I think unfair and I
and I think it's too bad because I you
know the funny thing is a lot of the
things that infuriate Republicans about
Senator McCain are things I tend to be
more agreement with them on some of the
things like immigration or the gang of
14 or judicial elections and so on but
in any case the what time I met senator
mccain i met him in a congressional
hearing and i decided he was actually
seated there waiting to speak because as
the senator he gets to go in the first
panel because his time is valuable and
then this the FEC Chairman I was on the
second panel because my time is kind of
valuable and then ordinary citizens were
relegated to the third panel they had to
wade through all the hearing you know so
senator mccain was waiting to speak and
i went up and thought I'd shake his hand
and say hi and you'd see that I don't
have a little horns in and you know it
would break the ice and we would be able
to talk because he refused he'd been
unwilling to meet with me and so I went
up to talk to them and I said senator
and he held out his hand and and you
know kind of instinctively and I took
sanding when he looked up and he saw it
was he yanked his hand out of mines I'm
not going to shake your hand and he said
you're a bully and a coward and you have
no regard for the Constitution and kind
of berated me for several minutes and
you know I this is not a story this
first time I heard told a story on
camera and I don't normally tell it I
have a great deal of respect for Senator
McCain as a bona fide American hero as a
man who has accomplished a great deal
but you know he doesn't need to be this
way toward people who ought to be his
political allies on a lot of things and
I really think that that he has a
certain you know anger on this issue I
think in part because he really doesn't
understand it and so he just gets very
frustrated with these people why are
they opposed to me on this
it must be a sort of a personal thing on
their part that they would do that and
and I feel bad about that but anyway
that's my relationship sir
senator Obama's decision not to take tax
money in the campaign is portrayed by
many as the death knell of the public
financing system that is the mistake
that opponents of public financing or
opponents of regulations have made over
and over and over and I here make it
again again and every time I'm gonna
says nope this is not the death of it I
heard you know September 11th was the
death became final we got more important
stuff to do there were a couple
different points and it was defeated in
the house or in the Senate because I buy
all this is the end of mccain-feingold
when george bush was elected president
to allow this is the end of mccain
feingold i've heard this over and over
and I hear now about public finest it is
not yet the first thing people who
believe and political freedom need to
understand is that the opposition the
regulators are relentless they care
about this issue they care a lot about
it they see this as the key to their
being able to impose their sort of you
know quasi socialists big welfare state
agenda on the rest of society because if
you can effectively muzzle the people
who are upset by that agenda you're more
likely to get that agenda through and
they are relentless they work 24-7 they
will be there and they will be back even
now they are working very hard and
pushing very hard for now what they call
full public financing of campaigns they
want to extend it to Congress they want
to extend it through the states they've
come up with this new name they call it
clean elections because if you go to the
voters and actually say we're going to
pay for we're going to give candidates
money to campaign or any of them your
tax dollars to campaign with voters vote
against it but if you call it clean
elections and ask voters to vote for it
it's kind of like asking them to vote
for a good economy or you know warm
fuzzy rabbits or something I mean of
course people are going to vote for it
they're pushing this they're pushing it
very hard they're backed by big money
just as mccain feingold in the campaign
to enact that wasn't backed by big money
and the curious thing here is they're
using the failure of mccain feingold as
proof that well we've got to have full
government takeover of campaigns now you
know because obviously mccain feingold
didn't work so the only solution trust
us is more regulation more of the same
you know the fact that we're more
heavily regulated than in our politics
than at any time in our nation's history
is just is just lost on them and
not relevant